what's up vlog as you guys know if
you're really paying attention I haven't
been investing a whole bunch the last 18
months because I think consumer web app
mobile app you know next Twitter this or
the uber that or the there being me of
this or the uber of that like just
boring a lot of fake entrepreneurship
but one place where I see huge white
spaces you guys know his voice and so I
took this trip to Seattle to the tech
stars voice kind of Amazon Alexa
incubator people that are building on
top of the Alexa skill platform and
obviously they'll be building on top of
Google home and Apple home pod as well
that's me is the white space and so this
talk is intriguing a little different
look gives you a little bit of my
different mindset of kind of how I'm
thinking about entrepreneurship and and
the white space of complete platform
shifts not the white space of the
nuances within a platform like social
media so really excited about it I hope
you enjoy it and I'll see you soon sit
there I would rather you guys be asking
questions real real pleasure to be here
thanks for having me and even long
before social I launched the e-commerce
wine business in 1996 right so basically
story of my life has been pretty much
more intuitive of what I think people
are gonna do not super data doubt not
super scientific about it just kind of
on my gut intuition actually taking it
way back as a kid I made a lot of money
selling baseball cards and the first
time I really remember this happening
was I was at a baseball card show a
normal thing that I would do in my
junior year of high school and for some
reason I just didn't like the way the
room felt like just it wasn't that I was
calculating how many people were showing
up or how much money people were
spending I just didn't like the way it
felt and literally within a month I'd
sold my entire collection and poured all
that money into comic books and toys and
that was right and basically intuition
and the wine business that I grew up
with you know around Oregon and you know
South American and South African wines
and so that's always been my place and
those spidey senses are completely off
the charts in this space and to be very
honest with you it's not I'm not
Nostradamus these spidey senses are off
to the races for you there's people that
have been doing this much longer it's
just to me I like to get into a very
specific time in the lineage of a space
I'm never smart enough or scientific
enough to get in super early thank you
so much as entrepreneurs as you guys are
I think there's times to get in super
too early for example in parallel in our
world there's a lot of people tackling
consumer VR and think like that's going
to be super remarkable and for me that's
still too early to be at scale and I
think a lot of people are gonna be not
practical and waste a lot of money and
time and I just think it's further away
before everybody's doing it and so the
things that I'm seeing in this space is
it feels that I just can't wrap my head
around a world in America for sure and
other parts of the world where in 48
months not everybody's doing this and so
that's when it gets good that's when it
gets practical and I'm also intrigued
because I think I've personally learned
I'm sure you as entrepreneurs and
innovators have learned we've learned a
lot about building on top of systems
whether the Apple ecosystem things of
that nature so it's gonna be interesting
how this all transpires but for me it's
just it's time it's time for me to get
educated it's time for me to make bets
it's time for me to make things it's
time for me to come and you know in a
world where I'm hacking every five
minutes you know I wanted to schlep here
and I'm thankful for the opportunity to
hang with you guys and gals and so it's
just in then the Gehry in one human
beings personal radar it's now just a
matter of time and if the biggest thing
in this room especially what if I get
luxury spent some time with you guys
individually to
it's just about staying alive until it
gets good the biggest thing that I think
you will get caught with and I've seen
over and over is are you running it
practically are you at the mercy of VC
or this incubator or anything else are
you at the mercy of anything over the
next 36 months are you capable of
understanding what it takes to do over
the next 36 months because you're right
like you're 100 your brain is a hundred
or 100 percent right now there's just
two variables can you be there when it
happens
and is there somebody else that that can
do the same thing better than you that's
it and so I think that's great because I
don't think there's a lot of spaces in
the world that look like that so I think
you've won the bigger part of the bet
which is the global strategy of what
you're gonna do with your time in your
life now it's about those two variables
that's that's what I would be spending
all my time on that's what I do spend
all my time on no no nothing like that
you know it kind of was watching and
knowing and seeing and got what God had
a device and so other people had a
device it was you know there was no
magic moment to me I only believed that
there are only a couple things that
matter to people health and money and
religion and I think time is way up
there and anybody who can't put the
pieces together to understand why voice
and time are a really interesting
variable are just missing this whole
point so it's inconceivable to me
anything
uber I passed on over twice in the angel
round trap you know if you go if if you
go open my first book the only person I
thank besides my family is Travis who
really good friends long before uber you
know I didn't invest in it and what I
did that I did have a moment when he
came to New York to ask for some help to
think about how to launch New York as
the second market my brother AJ and I
were meeting with him and he's like hey
we've got like a test alpha car in the
market can you try it
and AJ ordered the uber while we were in
the
there was something I don't know why
that hit me but there was something that
didn't happen to me in San Francisco
that AJ being in a high-rise in New York
hitting a button and it like saving that
time made me realize that day that uber
was selling time not selling
transportation so that's when I started
getting really crazy about time I'd
always been about lack of friction and
things of that nature but because all
the way back in 2010/11 time got crazy
important to me when the Boise thing
started becoming more on my radar I mean
I it's just such an incredible play and
so there was no one thing but it was
just the complete passion of how do we
save people time people always pay for
time time will always win so I would I
would go about a little bit different
way you know if that's a conversation
you're having I think the people in here
that will succeed are the ones who spend
no time on that I think you just need to
basically like that sounds like debating
things that mean nothing to me meaning
do you believe that every single [ __ ]
person is gonna have a device in their
home in 48 months and I think that
answer is yes and so then who gives a
[ __ ] what moment what commercial what
app does that what you know to me it's
cool I've assumed that to be true how do
I create what I want to create in that
truth and how do I make sure that I'm
there
draw two when the iPhone first came out
so many people have these devices in
their pockets and first thing is having
their 10 games entertainment if you
think about these cases in the future
you can get excited about what that's a
good question
um I mean I'm very very excited and a
couple of things that are personal I
just
how many people here know somebody
that's really into wine raise your hand
perfect so when somebody gets just a
little bit of wine knowledge they become
a straight douchebag so I've been on a
decade journey to like demystify wine
I'm really excited about you know the
idea of people being able to be at home
and tasting wine along with me and being
educated and learning I think there's a
lot of that kind of stuff I love the
idea of people learning how to fix their
car motor because there's an expert
right next to them so the expert space
excites me a lot like there's that when
you really play it out the chess moves
when it gets that sophisticated we're
gonna be able to have that communication
I think that's super fascinating I think
you guys are thinking about that right
if that's the conversation I think we
there's complete pattern recognition
into what things play first and I do
think what you're talking about is
called in my mind escapism right
something that like takes me away from
the fact the world is difficult or my
personal world is difficult and that's
entertainment and gaming and things that
just take me out of my real life
those are always very fruitful first
places to play because a you have a
creative set of people who are usually
playing and so yeah I could see that but
I do think the expert space is
intriguing that the person that makes
the first SAP that is really you know
advanced and can really help somebody
either really learn something cooking
you know
it's why I love IP like I'd love to be
owning Julia Child's IP right now right
you could do something really remarkable
and I'm sure her family never thought
years ago that it'd be deployed against
a voice infrastructure and she'd be
helping the world learn how to make
souffle
your question already there is no one
from Amazon in the room currently but
when you look at this this is the great
part about building everything you've
got to do um I have I've only been
really aggressive on the food on stage
and I curse and I'm crass and I'm a lot
of things that people don't like at
times on stage but the only time I was
really aggressively booed was at South
by Southwest when I said that Jeff Bezos
was better than Steve Jobs back in like
2010-11 like bad yeah I think I I'm a
very big big big Amazon fan I just think
you know only the government can really
stop him so um I think they're gonna
really play I'm less confident that
Google and Apple are gonna be great at
it I really am and then and then it'd be
cool you know to for me for me will be
really cool if there was somebody who
emerged that doesn't exist or we don't
bit war you know be really cool for me I
like that Nintendo started as a playing
card company wouldn't it be neat if one
of these big conglomerate big companies
finally realize that they should be
putting themselves out of business
instead of letting somebody else do it
and took all those dollars they had and
bet it on where the world's going so
like why couldn't BMW be a player they
could they're just not built to do that
but that would be rad if somebody got
smart
yes sir what's your name
Brian real pleasure
and by the way Brian I apologize but for
the whole group also like I've done a
lot of investing like if you want to go
on the business side not just on the
creative side of what you're doing feel
free to raise your hand good right yeah
you like that thesis is that a good
thought like do you see that okay yes
gets harder there's only a couple things
I think I understand and this is one of
them I am stunned by the fact that most
people build financial arbitrage
machines not companies just spending all
their [ __ ] time thinking about how to
do things to make the next fundraising
event happen so they can stay alive I
think I think startups in today's
environment 10 years of good times since
the bad era of the economy are way too
[ __ ] fancy like why can't you have a
service business like why couldn't you
hire two people instead of two less
developers which will take you nine
months longer to achieve your tech goals
but you could hire two people who could
do client work or consulting for
companies so you had cash coming in
there's a binary decision in advanced
technology companies that are startups
that the way it's done is you raise
capital you burn through a trace cavity
burn through and you have your event
right either become profitable company
you sell it the fact that there's no
practical parallel of well what else
could we be doing like what if there was
no venture money like what do you think
happens when the markets collapse these
companies figure it out when you're as
lucky
you guys aren't mobile or social
companies you're playing in a new field
nobody knows anything about
which means that there's an enormous
appetite from leaders to pay for a
knowledge transfer and so my biggest
thing is first of all forget about the
people you surround yourself you guys
everything's your fault
you're the founders you need to be in
charge of having a real structured
strategy to how to stay alive and
everybody's rushing to make the product
or do this thing and to me it's like
give up six months and that to do
something that's making you practical
dollars along the way that's just
something nobody ever wants to talk
about because everyone's so [ __ ]
fancy Bry you know everyone's fancy like
and I just think that's stupid I also
think it's compound ly stupid after nine
years of good economy you know like I
mean that the only thing that I think
makes me not think that the markets
would collapse in the next three years
during this era is that I think we have
a president who would do anything to
manipulate the economy not to fall
during his time other than that I mean
this is a long run of prosperity and and
nobody's running businesses like their
businesses because there's artificial
dollars in the system there's incubators
there's all this [ __ ]
so I would think about how to not waste
money and how to make money along the
way while achieving your business goals
and I know that that's just not the kind
of talk that's going on in our world
yes sir yes yeah with a speaker from a
speaker standpoint like so for example
you know what I think should be making
the single biggest bet in this space
the Toll Brothers construction company I
mean every home built going forward
should have an upcharge
huge profit margin for them where
they're like you don't need those
speakers it's just in right security
systems right the the people that secure
your homes
things of that nature so yeah I'm not
I'm sure there's I haven't done the
homework on this
I'm sure there's clearly an intriguing
window for the hardware in that form but
I think that's commoditized and there's
a lot of things that can deliver that
and I do think that that's dangerous
other than if you have great tech that
can then be put into a wall or bottled
water or what have you but like as a
consumer facing speaker play I think
there'll be a window but over time that
gets commoditized so you have that I
don't love when you have to nail not
only all the things we just talked about
but then the macro consumer behavior and
moment as well that adds another layer
of timing which usually forces you to be
less patient which is what I was talking
about right right like now you're
forcing it because you know [ __ ] we've
got 24 months before right so yeah I
would I'm far more bullish on people who
have got the textured around what's
making it sound great more so than the
physical product you know I think that
just plays out it you know right I mean
Amazon Amazon everybody else should be
making a smart refrigerator that has
speakers built into it so that not only
is it in fully penetrating your kitchen
but it's reordering every product for
you once you've used up a percentage of
that
yeah but there's also another thing
which some of these companies are
starting to experience too is that these
larger companies don't understand space
our thinking our new acquisition targets
yeah I mean I think the cool answer to
that question is that's very specific to
you right there's no right answer to
that what I love as you were talking
like [ __ ] that I should have brought up
that point too because that doubles up
the reason why to be practical and have
a parallel service business that's
bringing you revenue in because it's
probably the gateway to a more
significant acquisition opportunity
because they get to lease before they
buy and understand that you're smart and
you get it and we've seen through the
history if you're if you're here to make
a make that financial nut you know the
amount of AK you hires we've seen
someone got I mean we saw in social
ungodly exits where the guy or the gal
was getting bought I think that actually
doubles up why I think you should go in
but like it's up to you if you if
coca-cola you're doing a project for
them in parallel while you build your
thing and they want to offer you seven
million dollars I mean that's just or 70
or or seven billion I mean I think
that's I think that's 7 billion a lot of
more people here go for it I think I
think the punchline there being is
everybody here has their own
circumstances you know for me I had a
long long long time ago far less money
than I have now that was the money I
wanted to make then it became about
legacy and like you know playing the
game and a lot of different things right
not some people want to mask dollars
their whole life some people want to
want to have a don't like the idea of
earning out for 3 years because they
think I would be very empathetic if I
became best friends with everybody here
and a year from now everybody gets an
offer I could really see that tough
decision of like [ __ ] this is
life-changing money and this is my you
know this would be helpful for me but
I'm locked up for three years in [ __ ]
these next three years in this space
they're so fruitful so I don't think
there's a one-size-fits-all and some
people have stood
loans and sick parents and you get into
a million variables they both work the
amount of people that said no in the web
1.0 web 2.0 and social bubble and ended
up with Dikshit is a lot the amount of
people that said yes Instagram and
others could have gotten a lot more Bebo
super happy they sold for 850 million
dollars to AOL yeah you know so so you
know III think there's a lot of ways
that goes I think that's where you go
that's where you I get really worried
that mentorship is mentorships so
important but it can be substantially
overrated because mentors tend to love
to give the advice that they lived
through or they don't contextualize all
these human variables that I just
brought up so the answer would be all of
them however I'm a big fan of options so
I sure love the idea of you making money
along the way that also led to an M&A
opportunity it's a lot more fun to have
options than not you know it's funny I
think we all right like your experiences
lead to everything I grew up in a retail
liquor store and I would tell you that
voice I can already make the pieces all
the way backwards to it like customers
don't like waiting in line
nobody likes friction and retail is a
real good place because it's one thing
if you're a UI UX data nerd and you're
just looking at it's a whole other thing
when you see the person's venom in their
eyes and it got ingrained in me so early
on and I'm and I'm a depth vs. with guy
even though I love with and so I do so
much my stick
it's still the depth it's always the
depth so you know what I knew about
social was what I knew about email I
early it's just experience pattern
recognition early email
I bought a add-on luxury comms email
newsletter they had a million emails
newsletter and like they prove that you
know this is what's fun about being old
this stuff used to be why I was like you
a million email it was like you know
like it was crazy I paid a fortune like
we're such a small company it was like
five or ten thousand dollars which is
like a lot and I called my high school
friends to come into the store because
they were sending the email on their
email the banner ad which you know at
the point at that point there was some
banner stuff I was running on the web in
96th I was getting fourteen percent
click-through not point oh you know just
it was a different world has it always
well as will the next three years of
consumer voice be compared to 10 years
from now you guys are all gonna convert
in a way that people be like one day
like but I'm five thousand Twitter
followers I'd get more retweets than
when I had a million
it's just how it works a lot right
anyway nonetheless I had like hired four
extra people brought like seven friends
I thought we'd be packing and shipping
all day we're such a small shop and
twelve o'clock is when I was going to go
out and it's twelve thirteen and we have
like one order and I'm like like
devastate and try to figure out and then
I could never forget this moment I'm
like I'm such an idiot
it's nine o'clock in the morning on the
west coast it's you know not twelve it's
you know so sure so I feel better for
about 45 minutes until I get an email
from this guy who sold me the ad he's
like how's it going because they did
send it at 9:00 a.m. twelve my time and
I'm like like you know when you have
this you know what blood rushes to your
head and you can almost faint like that
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm in trouble it was
when I realized huh open rates and
clothes you know I didn't call it that
but open rates and click through ratios
were gonna matter to not just how many
you had and and basically since then and
why did so well in social was that was
my second row do I know that's when
people got to know me that was my second
row do I learned a lot about shopping
cart optimization and email and and so I
think about the depth not just the width
I you know you're not gonna care how
many people have it you're gonna care
how many people do the right thing
with it and so I think a lot about that
stuff so that's how I think about why do
I care about customer service because
its depth basically I think about things
very simply I'm a really great marketer
that's what I'll be known for but if
your product blows all my great
marketing is gonna do is expose it
quicker the product is the products the
product it matters you know and we do
all these things around it to make it
seem like it doesn't but it does and to
me depth and customer service you can
have 10,000 followers and right nobody's
paying their mortgage on likes so you've
got to figure out what metrics matter
right watch what happens in the podcast
space once all the data comes out now
right doesn't you know cool you got in
early and got a lot of subscriptions and
they even unsubscribed right so a lot of
people about to be exposed
yep you talk about
the first three things I put my money
into her Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
that's when I was not an investor so I
don't like talking about myself as an
investor because I got progressively
stupider which is why I gave you the
advice that he gave you what I've
learned in last six years is first of
all it's about the jockey not the horse
I'm far more interested about knowing
you and what you're about and how you
roll
because you got a pivot and change and
you know this like it's listen if your
idea is stupid like right if if your
horse is like you know a horse son like
those machines you put the quarter in
and you got to actually run a race
you're gonna lose like you know but but
it's stunning how important the CEO is
how important she and he is it just it's
stunning for me six seven years later
especially in this time because you're
gonna have to change like this you know
what's funny about a new space like this
some of the biggest wins are the ones
that go from B to B to B to C and vice
versa like literally just change your
[ __ ] business and you as a CEO have to
be the kind of person that can react to
reality versus you're obsessed with the
romance of your vision so I'm spending a
lot of time trying to get to know the
person
Phil and I Phil Toronto here who's done
who start us in my system does a lot of
nesting and help me run my last fund
we're not even invest that we haven't
even vest in the last year poor Phil is
like wants to punch me in the face like
you know like like because we think
things are overinflated everybody's a
[ __ ] entrepreneur everything's an
idea I mean guys let me just break it
down for you and I know you're in and
I'm in a - I like like if you knew
nothing it is kind of interesting that
an idea is worth four to five million
dollars that is what we're talking about
so it's very interesting times and I
think I'm glad we rise question we
started with that what I'm looking for
is especially because I want to invest
in this space who can get there in 36
months who can survive who could survive
and that's it because it's too early for
it too much and there's too much that's
unknown still and you're still I was you
know obviously I got the advantage of
sitting with you for a few seconds I'm
super
to hear how many people are diverse you
know and smartly I figured that I mean I
think this was gonna be about just
building skills and briefings but I'm
excited to get and by the way I'm
excited to get educating myself about
like the layers of like thinking against
not being at the mercy of the the
platforms or how do you go around it and
and then there's just like the things I
remember like yeah you know you just
thought yeah who was gonna be the
browser you know when I was like there
was no thought that there was really
even a chance of a Google coming along
you know so it's cool one things that
I'm very fascinated about is it seems so
clear who's gonna win this or who's
gonna be the platform's of an enormous
amount of curiosity of is there somebody
that we're not thinking about jumping in
you know so I'm looking for people that
are aligned with me up it specifically
in this space of like yeah like I really
have to be thinking about thirty six
months from now there's just not gonna
be enough users enough discoverability
enough adoption and so what am I gonna
do about it and anybody who's just gonna
rely on you know the demo day or the
introductions you guys make or they're
gonna raise some capital is fine and
I'll probably miss some good ones cuz
that is a absolute blueprint of success
I guess I'm just looking for a little
more ghetto a little more scrappiness
you know somebody who's so obsessed with
this being their lives do you know many
people are gonna be happy like you know
what bugs me the most is if tomorrow it
all melted I have millions of dollars
sitting in the system in limbo I'm just
gonna get emails they're like hey Gary
as you know the world collapsed you know
super super sad it didn't work out
[ __ ] sucks Trump what a dick huh yeah
I'm going to business school so we'll be
shutting down next week he's just
Sammy's what well Phil's bringing up a
story that I will you know I wasn't
gonna go there cuz honestly like you
just said dude my [ __ ] like he just
said it and the insides of my stomach
went hot this dude sat in front of me um
listen I get that I've done it but I
lived in a studio apartment with eight
family members when we came to America
like I had zero vacation days in my life
in my 20s
I worked so hard to where I am now the
stood sits in front of me I remember
$150,000 check personal and goes look
we're gonna shutting down the company
meanwhile you understand complete
left-field like literally a week earlier
dudes taking photos at Coachella and he
goes look I'm gonna be shutting it down
just wanted to thank you you know like
just need you to sign some doctor he
goes some like kind of sitting I'm like
you know I'm like disappointed but not
like dead I mean I've lost a lot it
wasn't that but then it got crazy he
goes before I said anything just no no
don't worry I learned a lot you know so
so I think I don't know I'm not looking
for that anymore he learned a lot yeah
he you know what he didn't because I
Evert Mike if I had my dad's personality
he would have I'm more like kind of like
silent but they're like a tit like he
right he lost because and he lost with
all the investors and he's really
important he was lucky you know he was
charismatic he was it was that stick he
had a lot of the good angels on it and
losing your name is so crazy
but that's what's about to happen when
it when it whatever happens there's so
much there's ungodly amounts of non
businesses in our world of startup
across all sectors people are gonna go
back to McKinsey and go back to Harvard
Business School
I had a experience a week ago with a
founder who just got the idea was racing
you know two million enemy but only
wanted to work with investors who
invested in founders and after that when
our coffee meeting I have to decide
whether or not I was invest in him
because there was so much interest right
how do you kind of reconcile the you
know investing in people and kind of the
timeline
I run the gamut my team will tell you
that I pick two intuitively and two
quick sometimes I can make a decision in
one second I basically married my wife
eight seconds of the knowing our you
know like so I can be pretty intuitive
that way however I look for cues anybody
that would tell me that was the rules of
the engagement I would tell them to go
[ __ ] themselves you know like you're not
gonna put a time limit on it you know
what I mean like you could have told me
after the fact or after we had a nice
meal you could emailed me kindly me like
hey I'm I've got pressure and I'm gonna
move but like that's just his psychology
move to get people to make irrational
decisions which means I don't like you
you know what I mean so but the I can
run the gamut sometimes the people
you've known for a very long time some
other times it's just you know right the
reason you liked a song the first time
you hear it or fell in love or or found
your partner here like it doesn't have
to be that complicated I'm overly
intuitive and not analytical so you know
mine tend to be quick or intuitive and
I'm okay with that as long you know for
I'm sure for the people that have been
successful like me with that style your
wins so outweigh your losses so you win
in a macro I like die you know one thing
I would tell you whether you're like me
or completely the other way and
everything's got to be about the math or
anything in between
it's just so much more fun to die on
your sword than on somebody else's so
regardless of what I think I'm a pretty
compelling come you know communicator if
this is not intuitively what you believe
like let it be like you know like
there's many plenty of voices coming
through here plenty of opinions if I
could leave you with anything just die
on your own sword it's better because
then you're doing I'm regret and regret
is poison
please go anywhere that was
life-changing but also I think it's very
good for me in my mind
100% example I know of course man first
of all first of all anybody else that
wants to recall those things it makes me
feel amazing so thank you look that was
a perfect example I saw I saw YouTube it
was four months old nobody knew what the
hell it was and in one second
of looking at him like this is gonna
[ __ ] change the world and I you know
I had never given a talk you know now
this seems insane but I'm thirty years
old and I'd never given a public talk I
never was in front of a camera I was a
businessman like I didn't you know I was
a good salesman that's this that's where
this stick came from but like so why I
thought it was a good idea to send one
of my stock guys to Best Buy and get a
camera and start a wine show and the
truth is I immediately you know I am Who
I am I thought I was gonna do QVC I
thought he was gonna come back I was
gonna pick three wines that we were
sitting on that weren't moving or
whatever the [ __ ] right put him in the
camera and go and literally from day one
he's setting up and we're setting up the
table I switch out the wines I go with
some pre bit I know what they are Verde
wines some real high-end wines and the
light goes on in the camera and I'm like
[ __ ] man if I go to a party in a year
this is all going you know how fast you
could think of a million things really
fast sometimes if I go to a party in a
year and somebody hands me a glass of
wine and says hey try this do you like
it I have to basically not be wrong it
can't be something that I told them was
phenomenal I'm like this is [ __ ] so
basically as I'm goat like as I'm in the
first thing I can eat you know it's
funny if I watch one library episode one
and I made a thousand of them for you to
give you guys context I know exactly the
moment in the first five minutes where I
made the decision [ __ ] no selling every
episode
for the rest of my life if I and it
caused me so much headaches
talk about the long game I lost
relationships and I'm I'm you know
there's people you do business with for
11 years and you saw you know how I did
that show like this this wine tastes
like a cow [ __ ] in your face you know
like like you know like they don't like
that you know like who like and so it
was a it was super interesting and
nobody watched it for the first 17
months that I did it nobody watched it
just nobody watched it and for the first
eight years that 2006 1998 for the first
eight years that I ran my dad's wine
business every month the revenue grew
more than twenty percent from the year
Pryor's monthly revenue every month and
fifty seventy a hundred but never a
month that wasn't twenty the first month
that I did Wine Library TV it was flat
and then it started declining because
all my energy was going and so you know
I was like you know that was a different
level of survival than what you're
dealing with that was the thought of
declining or flattening versus growing
was I using the best use of my time but
intuitively I knew that everybody would
watch youtube videos where I made a huge
mistake was I made a financial one if
you remember this
there was a startup called viddler that
let you tag it so so everybody was
making 30-second videos I was making
twenty minute videos and I was tasting
wines every seven minutes so I this
startup came to me and offered me seven
percent of their company because I was
like the breakout YouTube star to move
over and exclusively go on viddler and
they had this tech that was IP protected
of so you could just click the third
wine and just start watching YouTube
didn't have that yet you know still you
know so it was a huge mistake it was the
one time in my career I made a financial
mistake I picked finances over where I
thought the market would spend their
time you know and so I just you know I
knew it guys you know this is gonna
happen like it's it's super cool like
this is fun for me like this is why I
loved innovation you get that thrill
again I'm sure you have this feeling
right now cuz I have it with this space
it's that same feeling
you know it's probably why discovering
bands is fun right like I'm sure the
people that are great at it or like when
they see like when they see it they see
it like you know cool it is that every
one of you right now are either gonna
have your thing win or in 10 years the
thing you're working on right now in a
different iteration is gonna win like
either in ten years you're gonna be like
let me tell you how I did it or are you
gonna be like hey you know this thing
that we're all doing yeah I did that
back at 17 we [ __ ] it up but you know
it's that's cool you don't have that now
in other spaces you know hope you guys
enjoyed it voice is the next frontier if
you're looking to leapfrog because you
were late on social media if you were
late on Instagram or a vlog or a podcast
the Boise platform hope you enjoyed it
leave a comment what was the biggest
takeaway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]